[Music]
once you win at Nobel Prize do you
really need a side Hustle after
detecting gravitational waves from the
inspiring Collision of black holes
billions of light years away you think
that ligo could rest on its Laurels but
no scientists are trying to use this
phenomenal machine to detect the most
elusive form of matter in the universe
and that's what today's video is going
to explore dark matter and ligo two
great ideas that just might work better
together let's go
the early Universe was a very simple
Place primordial soup sounds complex but
it's actually pretty simple it's
composed of very simple ingredients
protons neutrons electrons and add a
pinch of neutrinos to taste heat with
billions of photons per barium for about
three minutes and poof the cosmic
kitchen produced all the lightest
elements on the periodic table
everything out of this chaos eventually
could form the building blocks of
galaxies Stars after all are formed from
giant Blobs of hydrogen that eventually
start nuclear fusing together their
protons to make helium and so on but how
did those agglomerations of hydrogen
know where to form well they formed
exactly where sufficient Dark Matter was
to create enough gravitational field
that these ordinary matter particles the
protons could collapse and heat up and
eventually have thermonuclear Fusion
begin
now we don't understand exactly the
distribution of dark matter so it
behooves us to look with as many
different techniques as possible because
the hydrogen atoms were not evenly
distributed we infer that there must be
gravitational over densities caused by
excess amounts of dark matter so we want
to learn as much about that dark matter
as possible once the gravitational force
causes gravitational acceleration that
creates enough energy to bind protons
together to make helium that process
begins to run away exponentially
but it's not as simple as it might
originally have sounded with all we know
about matter and gravity from our
simulations it's not possible to expect
that just the amount of ordinary matter
is sufficient to cause the gravitational
collapse to begin in the first place
so we want to look for the effects of
gravity from unseen matter so-called
dark matter which we've known about
since the 1930s we know it exists we
know it's a Known Unknown but we don't
know what it is we know it's a Known
Unknown from observations and
simulations on all sorts of cosmic
scales from the clusters of galaxies
that zwiki first studied to individual
rotation curves of single galaxies that
Veer Rubin and others observed we know
that dark matter exists on all sorts of
scales in the universe and we've talked
about some of the observations on this
channel in previous videos our Paradigm
for understanding Dark Matter suggests
that each Galaxy is actually surrounded
by a vast Halo of Dark Matter this dark
matter could be in the form of particles
or as we'll see soon it could be in the
form of what's known as a field a dark
matter field these Halos eventually
overlap and if you think about them as
sort of Venn diagrams overlapping in
three-dimensional space eventually get
these filamentary structures that form
and this is matched by Sim simulations
so from the smallest scales of galaxies
themselves up to enormous clusters of
galaxies such as the local supercluster
we know that dark matter tends to
agglomerate in specific regions that
would mean that gravity would be
concentrated along the most dense
regions of the gravitational force
fields produced by these dark matter
halos in particular the Milky Way galaxy
itself should have a copious amount of
dark matter and the Earth should be in
some sense experiencing this dark matter
as it moves around the orbit around the
Sun as the sun moves around and its
orbit around the Galaxy and as our
galaxy moves towards the great attractor
in the direction of the Virgo
supercluster so there should be a lot of
dark matter right now look there goes
some right by you right now now if you
could see it if you could look at it it
wouldn't be dark so we have to look in
other channels other wavelength regimes
or perhaps in completely new techniques
and that's exactly where today's video
focuses no pun intended Dark Matter
makes up about 30 percent of the
universe's mass and energy we know so
little about it you don't even know who
you are but it behooves us to look at as
many different techniques and
Technologies as possible and now the
team using ligodata has joined the hunt
there have been many studies attempting
to pin Dark Matter on ordinary matter
just that is not brightly illuminated in
itself but the case of say Stars white
dwarves or so forth or even super dense
concentrations of ordinary matter that
collapse to form black holes some of
these attempts have focused on so-called
Macho
Macho Man didn't you massive compact
Halo objects ordinary chunks of matter
or perhaps little black holes that will
distort the path of light rays from
distant stars in a way that we can use
to constrain how much dark matter there
is and in fact we know there is
painfully insignificant amount of dark
matter in the form of machos to account
for the missing matter that we know the
deficit between the ordinary matter the
condom matter work in prized of and the
dark matter that is suggested by the
observation of the expansion of the
universe the Hubble constant Etc we can
only use gravity perhaps to learn more
about dark Matter's nature John Wheeler
said that space-time tells matter how to
move the curvature of space-time is what
we experience as gravity but matter
tells space-time how to curve so it's a
complicated interrelated non-linear
process this gravitational force field
so we'd very much like to know on as
many scales as possible how gravity is
affected by the presence of matter dark
matter in particular and where does ligo
come into play we've talked about ligo
with two of the Nobel laureates who
received the 2017 Nobel Prize my friend
Barry barish and my friend Ray Weiss in
previous videos subscribe and link to
those videos now new scientists not
affiliated with the ligo team itself but
using data that's publicly available
from ligo are on the hunt for Dark
Matter signatures but what does dark
matter have to do with these massive
things like black holes and neutron
stars that ligo is renowned to have
discovered
well ligo which stands for the laser
interferometer gravitational wave
Observatory is one of the most sensitive
instruments ever made perhaps the most
sensitive instrument ever made by human
beings it consists of these phenomenal
interferometric arms two of them
separated by thousands of kilometers one
in Washington state and one in Louisiana
they're in the L-shaped configuration
that is the most probable and profitable
for detecting gravitational waves which
themselves have so-called quadripolar
distortions we'll speak about that in
future videos how these detectors
actually work but today is not about the
detectors and it's not about
gravitational waves either
it's about the basics of an
interferometer
an interferometer is a device that goes
back to the late 1800s some of the most
sensitive tools ever made for understand
the properties of light
it's made by shooting in this case two
beams of light two laser beams at right
angles and measuring the pattern of
interference as they come slightly into
and out of phase with one another they
come together in a very complicated
expensive and sophisticated device
called a beam splitter which splits and
combines the light beams after they make
their traverses through these four
kilometer long arms
now when the beams of light Collide they
can interfere constructively or
destructively and that can be used for a
variety of purposes it could be used to
measure the Distortion due to gravity a
gravitational wave in this case of one
of the arm's length scales being
modulated at the appropriate frequency
or wavelength due to the presence of a
gravitational wave passing through now
we'll shorten or lengthen the path
periodically and this is what has been
observed by over a hundred such ligo
observations of black hole in spirals
but here we're not using them to detect
gravitational waves we're not talking
about gravitational waves produced by
dark men or anything like that we're
using the complex and sophisticated and
highly sensitive probes of the
interference of light that can be
measured uniquely with ligo's
sophisticated beam splitter so these
Bean Splitters can measure distortions
over kilometers that are resulting from
something far smaller than a nanometer
displacement of these enormous Optical
path links lygo uses is a huge highly
powerful laser I'm laser it goes down
each tube each arm of the L-shaped tube
in each of the two locations and it's
sent out in these evacuated vacuum
tunnels the biggest vacuums on Earth
they bounce and recombine in the beam
splitter this causes the interference
pattern we can predict very very
accurately what the beam splitter will
see if there are gravitational waves and
if there are not as of today ligo's
recorded over a hundred of these compact
objects in spiraling together to produce
gravitational waveforms which are
successfully detected so this method
works exquisitely well and ligo
understands exactly what these signals
should look like in a wide variety of
black hole merger masses now most of the
time ligo is not detecting gravitational
waves from inspiring black holes
can I talk to you for a second please
and so it was supposed that you could
then use the so-called downtime when
it's not observing and it's sort of
passively just waiting for a next Black
Hole to inspire with another black hole
you could use that down time to actually
probe the nature of dark matter and
here's how they did it
with the incredible sensitivity enabled
by ligo researchers realized that the
hunt for Dark Matter could commence an
Earnest using this new technique
in December 2021 physicists from Cardiff
University led by astrophysicist Dr
Hartman Grote used the ligo setup to
search for what is known as a scalar
field Dark Matter the idea behind this
hypothesis is that dark matter is a
so-called Quantum field a field endemic
throughout the entire universe that gets
stronger with mass and self-interaction
there are certain models and high energy
particle physics theories that predict
such matter could exist and it could
explain the deficit between the observed
matter that we know in the matter that
we're made of in the matter we see in
luminous objects and the total amount of
mass energy we know exists it's a huge
deficit in other words in Dark Matter
there are multiple objects within a
cluster say a cluster of galaxies the
scalar field dark matter will pull them
towards the center of mass of that
cluster with a increasing and stronger
and stronger gravitational force
dark matter in this form would be weak
enough to not affect things on human
scales say it wouldn't affect the
effects of dropping an apple from the
Leaning Tower of Pisa but it would
certainly be strong enough when you have
enough gravitating matter in a cluster
of galaxies to account for the effects
the gravitational effects that we know
are present on individual Galaxy size
scales and on cluster size scales now
the team using the ligo data didn't much
look at the way the gravitational waves
would affect the lasers in transit as
the beam splitter and how it would be
affected by the presence of dark matter
so they're not using ligo to detect
gravitational waves or detect black
holes they're using the sophisticated
beam splitter and how exquisitely well
the ligo team not affiliated with this
group the ligo team understands its
sensitivity and has modeled its
performance the way a beam splitter
works is that it reflects half the light
that comes in at a right angle and lets
the other half pass straight through you
can see something like this happen when
you look at glare on a window any
transparent surface will let some light
in and reflect some out with the amount
of each being dependent on the angle and
the wavelength of light and the surface
preparation of the beam splitter with Dr
Groat and his team hypothesized was that
the interference caused by scalar Dark
Matter would actually cause the atoms in
the beam splitter to move subtly out of
place
which itself would cause an interference
pattern he's using it as a very
sensitive detector of quantum Fields a
new kind of dark matter
looking at a vast amount of data the
team founded no evidence that scalar
Dark Matter Fields were active this
doesn't rule them out completely just
because you can't prove it doesn't mean
it's not true but it does mean that
scalar field Dark Matter would have to
be about a million times weaker than
previously thought it also rules out a
lot of major subsets of scalar field
Dark Matter models and it rules them out
as contributing very much to estimation
of how much dark matter they can
contribute to
it's worth noting that the team doesn't
believe that scalar field dark matter is
the only kind of dark matter or form of
dark matter to exist if that were true
it would mean that we really have no
clue as to what dark matter is it's just
another candidate for Dark Matter there
are other candidates we mentioned machos
earlier there are other candidates such
as so-called weekly interacting massive
particles or wimps I've talked about
neutrinos on this channel as being the
only form of dark matter that we know
exists neutrinos after all suffuse the
universe to have masses albeit quite
tiny and they only interact weekly and
gravitationally as far as We Know there
could be other particles like this that
either don't interact with the other
three forces of nature the strong force
the weak Force the electromagnetic force
and these forces could be particles or
they could be fields that interact and
we just don't know there are other
candidates in particular candidates
called axions or dark photons and the
more that we investigate the more we're
going to learn about these types of
matter and I'll talk more in future
videos about axions and about dark
photons such exciting candidates that
we're just now getting sophisticated
tests of both on particle physics
experiments and on Earth and also
looking astrophysically with tools like
the Simon's Observatory and other
experiments we're clearly at a point
where both scalar field dark matter and
wimp dark matter have failed to be shown
to exist with significant evidence
neither can be ruled out entirely and
it's entirely possible still that
another type of Dark Matter exists on a
scale too large or too weak for us to
detect the team isn't discouraged though
the search has been called a phishing
Expedition and we all know that you
never stop just because you didn't catch
a fish if a cheaper hand with you so
it's a proof of concept for now and it's
a very very special and encouraging one
to continue looking for old particles
with new technologies
so the experiment proved that ligo isn't
just good for detecting black holes it
can be used to constrain models of dark
matter and even modifications of gravity
itself what's exciting to me is that
these researchers didn't request to
build an entirely new particle physics
detector or some new type of telescope
or technology they're using existing
telescopes in this case ligo and even
existing data they didn't even have to
run ligo for a longer amount of time to
collect these data it's an exciting but
preliminary First Step the team has
already begun making plans and doing
preliminary Research into other Dark
Matter candidates such as axions and
dark photons we'll discuss those in
future videos there's even more that can
be discovered and attempts to possibly
measure quantum gravity large-scale
kilogram chunks of dark matter all to
try and understand the progression of
how our universe came to appear the way
it does with luminous structures
sprinkled on top of invisible Dark
Matter Halos all of this is allowing us
to get more light on Dark Matter
understand the nature of gravity and in
turn understand how matter and space
time itself came to be
check out this video that I made what is
dark matter and make sure to subscribe
to my channel so you don't miss an
episode
[Music]